what's going on there reject nation no
john coming in today so it's just am wah
but i'm the one who rewatched all the
stranger things uh just a couple of
months ago a little fresh in the noggin
i hope and today we got ourselves a clip
stranger things for official clip 11's
powers if you guys can leave a like that
would be very much appreciated also
please subscribe and click that
notification bell reason why is because
well on may 26th we watched top gun
gotta shoot edit that review and then at
midnight that night two episodes there
will be one come out the same night
obi-wan comes out all the stranger
things four comes out at least part one
of stranger things four releases so it's
gonna be a lot to cover just in that
weekend alone and some of you guys might
not know this but the way we handle
things behind the scenes here usually
one episode of television if it's an
hour long takes roughly four and a half
to six hours to make them fully complete
to be visible here on youtube that's why
clicking that notification bell is going
to be the best reward you can do to make
sure you get notified when our video is
up that's how it works all right let's
do this
[Music]
[Applause]
goddamn bullies
[Music]
the new [ __ ]
what the hell was that
oh
oh no
as sad of a clip as that is i cannot
wait for this season man what's neat
about watching this clip is in stranger
things season one mike dustin and lucas
sometimes i gotta count them on my
fingers because i'm like am i getting
the names wrong with mike lucas and
dustin they were getting bullied
severely in that first season then
eventually 11 stepped in and became like
their their protector of sorts and
really stood up for them and it was
really cool to have her in their corner
and then now to see in this season where
it's picking up where eleven still does
not have her powers after the
cliffhanger of season three how she's
just going to school being like a normal
girl and now having to go through the
experiences of what those three and will
included is just will wasn't in you know
a large part of season one because he
was stuck in the upside down the four
boys had to endure and now she's gonna
be going through it herself i'm
wondering if it's gonna be like
repetitive or really explore something
different here and i imagine it'll be
different just due to the fact that 11
so much of her character has been like
identity soul-searching like who is she
when she's not stuck in the rainbow room
who is she not under the the power hold
of dr brenner as she's slowly been
uncovering her identity and finding
herself being completely stripped of her
powers is in this position where how can
she find
this other version of strength and
endurance while dealing with things that
a lot of children deal with in high
school i think it's going to be a really
fascinating season to explore because i
keep trying to pick up on like what
might the themes be of season four
because when i rewatch seasons one
through three it was cool watching them
all back to back like not taking a break
because like in season one so much of
that is inflicting trauma you know
dealing with the anxieties of loss you
know like you had hopper and joyce and
you know hopper had lost his kid that's
something i totally forgot about
honestly the whole storyline with sarah
it's already watching it and so hopper
had lost his kid and then joyce dealing
with the the fears and paranoias and how
it's taken a toll on the city so
everyone's being inflicted with this
trauma and dealing with so much unknown
and then season two dealt with so much
with post-traumatic stress disorder
season three was all about you know
learning to let go and move forward i
imagine that they're all eventually
gonna be going back to hawkins here but
seeing it being brought back to this
element of bullying would and this is
not the final season because usually in
like a movie format you know you you
circle back to the beginning in a lot of
ways so this isn't the final season but
something about just this one scene
alone feels indicative of the first
season and watching 11 go through the
experience that the boys had to deal
with i wonder like what she will
discover about herself how she'll learn
to display strength without you know
freaking killing people or snapping
their necks or some [ __ ] but at the same
time i am hoping that stranger things
four will give us some type of cathartic
release where she does get her powers
back uh i mean it seems inevitable at
some point 11 will get her powers back
i'll be very surprised if she doesn't so
i wonder if like at some point she will
bully this they say her name was angela
ashley i forget i could play it back i'm
not going to this specific you know mean
girls bully the the rachel mcadams
character if 11 will come back and you
know do some type of bullying [ __ ] not
kill her
but you know make her piss her pants or
some [ __ ] i don't know and then it makes
me wonder too like will has also been
just such a lost soul a big part of
season three with will you know after
being stuck in the upside down and
dealing with his own trauma he just did
not know how to move forward you know he
was clinging on so much to what the past
used to be like now that he's with 11
there's two folds here that i'm really
excited for a the type of lost identity
soul-searching there's a lot of things
like thematically about 11 and will that
feel so complementary towards one
another and so i'm excited to see them
have scenes with each other what kind of
bonding will they have well they end up
being a little bit more brother and
sister like especially now that 11's
living with them what will become of
their relationship and what will
eleven's experiences of being bullied
due to will specifically it's like she
can probably confide in him will will
learn to stand up to the bullies
you know for her as well like it's funny
that it took four seasons for them to
seemingly have you know a lot of scenes
together because these two uh in a lot
of ways have been you know the biggest
outcasts of of the ensemble other than
like jonathan for these two of the same
age range like being these targeted
bullies who deal with like the worst
case of trauma all the time feeling far
from normal or feeling far from the
average kid i'm looking forward to like
what kind of you know empathetic
relationship they deal with one another
and really i'm hoping that they see a
school counselor this season because i
feel like they need it with all the crap
they've been through man i'll throw us
out there too i know a lot of people
weren't big fans of that episode in
season two they felt like a backdoor
pilot i think the the character was
eight i think though that to to wrap up
the story especially with eleven i do
think it would be a bit of a necessity
to bring her back i would like to see
that story resolve maybe in season five
maybe they won't do it this season but
i'm hoping that at some point eight does
actually come back into the series
because everything that eleven's
experiencing here goes in conjunction
with a lot of the reasons why eight was
trying to pull 11 into her specific
modern day world last thing i'll say you
know i hear that this season's gonna be
dealing a lot with horror gonna be more
horrific than the other ones it is
interesting knowing what eleven's powers
are knowing how much stephen king
inspiration there is in this show one of
the horror films i grew up on a lot was
the movie carrie and i am sort of
getting carry vibes but the reason why i
don't fully go there is only because of
the fact that carrie you know like
murders everyone in high school and i
don't think they're gonna put 11 down
that dark of a path but regardless i do
like the idea that it still plays on
that nostalgia factor that i i think
that duffer brothers handle so well but
anyway guys thank you so much for being
here what did you think about this clip
for stranger things four i'm very much
excited for it i feel like this is gonna
be an epic ass season leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click the
notification bell leave a like
eric horstmann you messaged me the other
day i hear you're in some recovery sorry
to hear that try to try giving you a
call i would really like you to call me
back eric
get it joyce
i miss you i have been thinking about
you a lot i was just telling olivia the
other day if [ __ ] gets really bad
must take a trip to atlanta that's
what's gonna get me to go to atlanta is
if your life is in danger that's the
only way i'm gonna go to atlanta but no
i feel like you're gonna be okay in the
end just know you're in my thoughts
significantly you don't strike me as an
individual who believes in god so i
won't say you're in my thoughts and
prayers but here are my thoughts at
least i really miss you man and you mean
the world to me i hope you you give me a
call back before this video goes live
cause um i need you to approve this
shout out because i i feel like i might
have already said a little too much